tu là je suis là parce que tu as gardé
un peu d'énergie pour moi toujours merci
benoît garder l'énergie pour dos et qui
tout semble oui je prends ça comme un
compliment vient signer un accord de
tueur en série a à deux gardes du corps
oui je suis avec m si ça allait barder
sosie vocal degré d'alcool et de fatigue
oui bon tour en sachant que donne moi au
milieu quentin là et grégoire ici bien
le bateau savoir faire pour venir
coiffer les décors à tous c'est comme
les gens qui arrivent sur les plateaux
10 ans tutoie avec quoi que les
objectifs ont parlé de la focale sont
gelés entre poser la question le petit
la coquette et s'habille comme en orient
est dépité 2ème epr était inculpé c'est
ce qu'on a voulu bien comme la est-ce
qu'on va prêtres sont des tabourets on
s'est posé la question avec des édifices
et une tonne de lait frais au bazar avec
des les fortes gelées coûte le petit
appel à la cei donc de ne plus poser de
questions à l'autre extrême d'anna tu
sais le vétéran suis lâché le siloc ce
qui est très curieux c'est de rester
cool ouverte salue les couilles salut
les gars émission de la grosse brûlure
main salut laurent bon ça fait commencer
un quart d'heure on s'affirme à garda
prenons 200 résidents qui va fêter
j'ai fait ça fait longtemps que je me
suis même demandé savait pas encore mais
je suis triste
ça fait presque dix ans que l'on m'a plu
invité il ya eu un combat genre
passenaud fois la même blague on sait
qu'ils n'ont pas écouté on rigole déjà
être rentré on devrait tous être
ailleurs nous aussi on a des privés
maintenant il est horriblement mourier
anton petit truc je n'aimerais pas
devoir refaire toute l'émission parce
que tu n'as pas vous dire que sur un
filin convaincu que ça se passerait
bravo monsieur gillett
ouais maintenant que benoît laval et on
rapporte que ça ça couine
merci merci merci merci dix ans pas
maintenant il faut plus y en avait quand
même montré de la mauvaise volonté par
hasard qui veut lécher mon tort vraiment
bien merci
carey sur mahomet focus on est élu se
nomme on y est pas si j'ai fait face au
numéro rien depuis quatre mois
maintenant la toile n'a pas eu l'air de
tout va pas me dire que d'ap a crevé t2
qu elle ne l'a pas
[Musique]